it's really crazy this is not unrelated
to what we're talking about right now so
this has happened I think since we've
been live Kevin Spacey uploaded this
video on his YouTube channel where he's
in character as Frank Underwood and
since this has come out today he's now
been indicted on rape charges and met
Massachusetts I believe whoa felony rape
charge
so it's his plea to get his job back
this might have come out without him
knowing that was gonna happen I don't
know I was to see if you wanted to watch
and see what he's doing
should we watch it if we're watching
we're gonna tube news it's fair use ish
ish I mean it should be definitely fair
use we can only swatch a minute or two
something like there are a second
7-series doing its Washington's hands I
know what you want oh sure they may have
tried to separate us but what we have is
too strong is too powerful I mean after
all we shared everything you and I I
told you my deepest darkest secrets I
showed you exactly what people are
capable of I shocked you with my honesty
but mostly I challenged you and made you
think and you trusted me even though you
knew you shouldn't so we're not done no
matter what anyone says and besides I
know what you want you want me back of
course some believed everything and I've
just been waiting with baited breath to
him II confess it all they're just dying
to have me declare that everything said
is true and that I got what I deserved
wouldn't it be easy if it was all so
simple only you and I both know it's
never that simple not in politics and
non life but you wouldn't believe the
worst we'll see Karen Karen yes I
supposed to be dead in the show correct
strange that's strange to watch because
well you know what's strange is he seems
a little off his game
right I mean I don't know if he's
playing Frank Underwood yeah he seems a
little off like okay we're a little
tense on that one let's uh yeah let's
get into this
you're Frank Underwood come on man Kevin
you're Frank under it
I'm Frank Underwood and then boom hit it
a second time it's a second take felt
smoother second take felt smoother you
know it seemed like acting it's weird
it's not like it's great character that
characters [ __ ] great character I
mean the Frank Underwood characters like
one of the all-time TV characters but
that's just weird he just brought him in
the real life for statutory fox news
according to Fox News but this is what
everywhere else - he shared this video
as he's announced that he's facing
felony sexual starts alt charges for
assaulting a teenage son of a former
news anchor and then Nantucket bar in
2006 - jeez she thought he was going off
on that powder
oh god knows the power they give you and
what you buy in so just to make that
tape just shows you how [ __ ] creepy
is good I really think to be that good
at acting you gotta be out of your
[ __ ] mind Kevin Spacey's a bad
[ __ ] when it comes to acting all
the horrible things he's done aside
there's a there's a quality about
someone that's that good you know
they're just got a like a certain amount
of insanity together this is not
apologizing for his actions everything
he did is horrendous but I mean to be
surprised that you're seeing him seem
crazy there no that's not surprising
he's too he's too good to not be crazy
like I would assume that they're all
when they're not crazy I'm shocked
you know when someone there's a you know
seems to like Daniel day-lewis doesn't
seem to be crazy right he just seems to
be obsessed it seems to be obsessed with
work maybe I'm wrong I think all those
brilliant [ __ ] are out of their
mind
says his out of his mind as the